hey what is up guys mkbhd here and as
much as youtube analytics tells me about
the people that watch these videos what
devices they watch it on what browser
you're using what operating system
you're using one thing it doesn't tell
me is how many people click to toggle to
watch
in 4k
how many people actually click that
wrench and watch it in 2160p i have no
idea at the beginning of 2014 after last
year's ces we were looking at 4k in its
infancy basically and as much as a lot
of people would have liked to have said
that was the year of wearables it was
quietly the best year yet for 4k so
about a year ago youtube started
supporting 4k uploads officially and
things have heated up a lot since then
so 4k has gotten immensely better in two
ways
one recording 4k and two watching 4k so
for watching 4k it's simple you just
need a 4k display a 4k tv some panel
with a 4k resolution to watch the
content on uh for me i picked up these
asus pq 321q again about a year ago and
when i first got them these are serious
they were about thirty five hundred
dollars a piece
the price has gone down under three
thousand under twenty five hundred in
fact under two thousand dollars they're
hovering around fifteen hundred bucks a
piece now a year later after i got them
i'm not mad or anything but it's less
than half of what i paid for them a year
ago and that's been the general trend
with these 4k displays and these 4k tvs
they're dropping a lot in price as
they're commoditized and start to be a
lot more popular and then there's this
this is the 5k imac not 4k
5k it's the highest resolution
commercially available display that also
happens to have a computer built in as
imacs do so this 5k panel has a
resolution of 5120 by 2880 so it's
actually four times the 2560 by 1440
that other 27-inch monitors are it's a
crazy amount of pixels and i love it
these things are super sharp when you
get right up close to it you still can't
see any pixels it's awesome for video
editing photo editing really any visual
graphics work you gotta love it and the
technologies that make it possible one
of my predictions for ces this year in
2015 was that we would see a lot more 4k
tvs and of course we did basically we
see that everyone who makes a tv now
makes some 4k tvs so they're everywhere
they're lowering in price like every
month i'll actually leave some of my
favorite 4k panels in the description
below some of the tvs and monitors i've
gotten hands on time with that i can
actually recommend including the asus i
use now
so clearly it's getting easier to watch
4k
but what can you watch in 4k what can
you actually watch on these 4k tvs well
in addition to all the 4k tvs coming
down in price we also see a whole bunch
of 4k cameras coming down in price and
existing more i talked about this in my
ces highlights video but we have a bunch
of 4k handycams now we have a bunch of
4k action cams the new 4k gopro and even
a ton of smartphones coming out that can
shoot in 4k so regular people can shoot
4k video too so we have all these
cameras that can shoot in 4k and we have
all these tvs that can show 4k videos so
now we just need them to connect we need
them to work with each other and there
are two main players that are making
this happen right now netflix and
youtube on netflix you can already watch
a bunch of new shows in 4k that are
being shot in 4k and youtube is also
supporting 4k really well in fact a ton
of youtubers including the ones that i
was hanging out with at ces are all
rocking 4k cameras and uploading 4k
videos all the time including yours
truly so this video you're watching
right now is also available in 4k if you
want to check it out fun fact i did this
video last year this 4k state of 4k uh
using a 1080p camera so i upscaled it to
make it look 4k
i mentioned at the beginning i don't
know how many of you guys are actually
clicking to watch these videos in 4k but
even if there are a bunch of you with a
4k display or a 5k imac out there i
still don't know if your internet or
your computer can handle watching 4k on
youtube since it requires extra
bandwidth for these bigger files and
extra processing power to push all these
pixels so and half of you guys are
watching on your phone anyway so it's
definitely not 4k there even though it
can be up to 1080p or sometimes 1440p
either way the point stands 4k now is
way more prevalent than it was even a
year ago today i feel like i've said 4k
a lot in this video either way 4k is
everywhere you're going to see a lot
more people buying 4k tvs black friday
is going to be probably this is going to
be the year people buy a 4k tv on black
friday uh you're going to see a lot more
4k laptops start to roll around that has
already begun and
as much as it seems ridiculous and as
much as it might seem completely
unnecessary and a waste uh you're gonna
see 4k phones sooner or later and
probably a year or two we're going to be
having 4k displays in our pockets as
insane as that sounds but the connection
that we talked about earlier is being
made so thank you youtube for supporting
4k this early and when people come back
to watch these videos in maybe one or
two years on their new 4k tv or their 5k
imac they're going to appreciate all
those extra pixels and that crispy 4k
video so if you're looking to buy a tv
for the long term this year or if you're
looking to buy a camera that you plan on
using for a long time
might as well make it 4k because 4k is
here to stay that rhymed thanks for
watching i'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace